[Music]
it's the biggest technology that's ever
happened in the history of life
outside of things like [ __ ] fire and
like
the printing press is the one that i
keep going back to television phone
fine but this is like printing press
10.0
every piece of our life is everything is
correct
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
guys i'm here with gary vee the famous
garyvee for this episode of next with
novo
so gary what did you think we frickin
met with michael rubin on the all in
challenge
and i was kind of blown away because i
was like god who is this guy who just
keeps talking and getting [ __ ] done and
i know everything i got it i got it i
got it
so and i showed up thinking who are
these people
i love meeting people nothing's you know
nothing's more fun than when you meet
someone when you're trying to do good
you know our our relationship will
always be bounded by we met
when we were taking enormous i mean i
was spending 12 hours on that [ __ ]
thing in the beginning
every day and we raised 60 million
dollars to help people get food during
covet and the people that donated
got crazy [ __ ] being in movies swag it
was cool so full disclosure you know
michael rubin started this thing he
brought in gary brought in alan tish
and he asked me if i'd help him and it
was the thing i've probably been the
least successful at in my life i had a
ton of fun doing it
i was almost no help but it was a ton of
fun but your mustache was epic i had a
great mustache
that i remember and listen to your point
like everybody had different roles
different things happen to your point
there's many things i get involved in
where the intent is the epic and
sometimes it doesn't go exactly how i
thought
but this is what i love about time to
your point
maybe the you going after super whales
for big donations first of all that was
hardcore hail mary right b
you were saying things in meetings that
helped the process
i think you know i think people
sometimes spend too much time on
thinking
the output was the only kpi sometimes
one person says one thing in one meeting
and it matters
that's what i remember i remember
thoughtfulness and the mustache the
mustache the mustache is what i think
about first
but the thoughtfulness is definitely
like it helped like you work through
things with people you think
you have confidence listen we will look
back at this combo in 80 years i'll
listen to it 80 i'm not sure i'm gonna
make it that far but sit 40
and i'll be like wow a lot of that was
right oh [ __ ] i really [ __ ] didn't
have that right and that's fun that's
like
i just want people to be less scared
i don't think that many people feel that
terrible for the three guys that went
out of business
now listen by the way on the record i do
i feel bad for somebody went out of
business
they were like like like i know nothing
about our stunningly wealthy guys they
are stunningly good investors they will
regroup and and they'll live happily
ever after they're they're
but i actually think that they lost
their investors a ton of money listen i
think compassion and empathy
is a and sympathy is a required way to
get back to a non-separating society 100
i i'm to your point i i don't know any i
don't know the names of any of them
melvin is that one melvin capitalist
good right and so there's humans
underneath it i'm sure right
so i don't know i don't know who the
humans were talking about are three of
the best gen
investors of the generation right so i'm
sure to your point they'll be fine yes
they've hard assets
sleeping with giant short positions and
never expected a hive of bees would come
all at once it's like the african bees
are here yeah and by the way
by the way that's just business yes
that's like them shorting
the people that that's just business to
me what what what is interesting from a
anthropological view from a market's
view is that
after that first push and you squeeze
the shorts
then it became david verse goliath then
it became class warfare then it became
generational warfare
you know i had a conversation very
thoughtful combo last night this is me
just talking about the combo
where the person didn't like
la didn't like the leverage that some
people played to stop
it from a tech standpoint and an
infrastructure standpoint
but loved what facebook and twitter did
to stopping
other voices oh yeah so like to me
there's a bigger question listen aoc
was fear for her fearful for her life
uh in that capital and and every
progressive said this is
horrible i can't believe they attacked
the capital they put our lives at risk
when the mob was literally going after
wall street burn it down it was a
nihilistic
mob i mean one of the guys uh
you know who's fun went out of business
got death threats i put some
neutral comments on and the vitriol that
came to me and twitter and i'm kind of a
crypto guy i'm
part of the progressive movement that's
saying we need to remake things
and just because i was trying to like
give the facts well i think
death threats i also think anger yeah i
also think there was a there was a
different energy
i think that's a good market that's a
whole different conversation i think we
live in a society
where you can hide behind a keyboard and
everyone's always tougher
in in the mod you know behind the veil
right
like if you look at whisper and secret
which are historic social apps
that a lot of people bet on that i
didn't it was the reason i didn't bet on
it is because
everything i've done in my career is
based on what i believe in humanity
and so i believe that whisper in secret
we're not going to win
because i believe that when you have
anonymous you get the worst version of
people
where they feel safe to express their
hurt so i'm not even mad at them
i'm not even mad at those people i just
know that's their safest place
to share their internal hurt
and so i didn't and those platforms
continue to not do well
as a matter of fact the business models
of all these anonymous platforms
is to put hostage of the people look at
some of the
you know look at you know yelp and
glassdoor like it's a very
interesting ecosystem so i think it's a
fascinating conversation
should everyone need a blue check i kind
of think so but the other side said
yeah i mean that goes i mean listen back
to like you being a crypto guy from wall
street i'm a social media guy
who wants every metric hidden i don't
want followers shown
i don't want blue checks i just think
it's gonna be healthier for people
i'm good i'm good when i suck i good
when i do checked
i'm good when i'm gary v right now well
i say blue check because then you know
who the guy is
oh yeah so we don't have that so yeah i
mean that was my big it was funny i
loved facebook when it first came out
because i'm like cool people can't hide
like they do on
like early stuff like you know and and
that lasted for a while and then it was
the opposite and now everything's
privacy and that's fine listen i just
think it's i think it's great
i think it's progress i really do i
think that there's
incredible progress going on my biggest
fear
is the regulation of the internet itself
yeah
i think we're making tremendous progress
there's incredible thoughtfulness
i really believe it plays out in a level
place where merit and good stuff i'm
happy about everything that's going on
while being very conscious that the
inner what will likely lead this i think
you've got both sides of conservative
progressive movements
willing to regulate the [ __ ] out of
american internet without realizing what
that actually means
i think we're dangerously close no it
won't listen but it was funny we had
this beautiful inauguration amanda
gordon gives this poem everyone i know
had a tear in their eye
it was like ah normalcy and two days
later we have occupy walls
yeah but i don't but i think i think two
days later you have actual
capitalism i actually disagree with that
uh let me rephrase
that's not what i disagree with because
i understand where it comes from i take
a different angle at it
i actually think two days later we had
true
capitalism i loved it yeah
i don't think anybody let me phrase for
context for everybody's listening
to the point of the buying to be frank
i'm so undereducated
on citadel's relationship with robin
hood i actually am so basic that i don't
even know
how this all works meaning why they had
the leverage of like the bids go
through them and the trading like i
don't know it literally i don't know
so i come here you know very authentic
like
i don't know if like the because i also
know correct me from wrong novo
it wasn't just a robin hood e-trade and
the others also halted it because i
guess
the thing above the thing stopped it and
they all get affected by it
the clearinghouse the clearinghouse
doesn't have enough money to support the
clearinghouse
and the sec said whoa this is growing so
fast
these banks aren't well these trading
entities right robin
don't have enough capital regulatory
capital and and so you got to slow down
right now here becomes that's fair
regulation we want regulations
here's what i don't think people are are
um
educated enough about people are always
like this game is rigged i'm like
take a step back you can re-rig the next
game what do i mean by that
what people cry about what they can't do
but don't focus on what they can do for
example
people can decide in their companies
that they don't want to
do the 401k they don't have to support
it
they can buy they can not put money in
tomorrow you could go buy like
take the money out buy something look
what's going on with
we don't blockchain you know nfts
my favorite one of everything that's
happening sports cards which
then means comic books toys paintings
chachkas
cars watches like [ __ ] can
i laugh at people's naivete on how basic
this combo is that same group
can have 20 000 people decide that
these sneakers are interesting look at
these cool kicks i got you know what i
mean so like
like i like what's happening is the
acceleration of supply and demand
and cultural norms so to me
because it's wall street there's a
little bit of like [ __ ] that
well there's way more [ __ ] that [ __ ]
going on wait wait till college gets its
day
but so no vote real quick oh collar's
gonna get crushed college is a [ __ ]
joke no really come on i'm i know people
think like because i was a bad
no kids are getting hurt people like mad
that they like lost a couple like 40
bucks on wall street on a trade i'm like
you're seventy three thousand dollars in
debt for a piece of paper that gives you
dick
we have forty four hundred colleges in
america four thousand four hundred
colleges
that's probably three thousand four
hundred too many i mean brother
they're charging full price right now
for [ __ ] zoom classes that
if they listen to this podcast they'll
learn more about in an hour than the
entire semester
of that dog [ __ ] they get at the state
university yeah
no it's it is interesting we we passed
this myth that you need to go to college
to do well in life
everyone believes in the story we
haven't what we're not past that myth
no we we we we created oh passed on i'm
just on this myth yes we do yes
and therefore if you're a parent if
you're a student you think
i'm not good unless i go to college and
then the economics say well geez if you
look a college graduate does a lot
better than non-college graduate
and so we're in this transition big one
a big transition i agree this one this
one's going to fall
hardest yeah and the pyramid is going to
go like this as opposed to
correct that one's gonna be fascinating
to watch and i by the way on the record
for people that follow me
zero pleasure zero i don't know anything
against nc state
i have no feelings towards michigan i
don't have any ill will towards yale
and even i think yale and a couple other
brands survive because of brand
but i have sadness and compassion in my
heart for the
enormity to the point where people
believe that the government should be
i'm like [ __ ] that
you made a decision what about
accountability you decided to go
like you didn't have to well yeah but
again
people often aren't in control of their
own decisions these stories are so
powerful and everyone's saying your
kid's got to go to school or you're a
terrible parent
and so they sacrificed their life to
send the kids to school if we go by what
everybody says
then like i mean like now you're getting
into the truth of it all
the truth of it all self-esteem
self-awareness insecurity
like i wish the whole country had gotten
to this self-introspection
self-awareness itself
it can sometimes all the carnage and all
the disruption leads to it
i'm sitting pretty like if we can just
hold our breath
i mean the thoughtfulness of combos that
are going on right now is incredibly
good
that is well good that's the punch line
that's how
change happens that's how and but but
let there be no confusion
humans will always have self-interest
like this this
this nobleness makes me laugh like
there's not a [ __ ] listening to this
or in the 8 billion of us walking around
that doesn't have a human shortcoming
and so when you pick on one person for
being two about that money
somebody else is pissing on you because
you're [ __ ] terrible for the
environment
or if you're talking about this you're
you're great on black rights but you're
horrible and transgender or you're this
like like this we have to get thoughtful
about giving some people for
like we're suffocating people's ability
to say i'm sorry and to say i need to
figure this out you definitely don't do
sorry well in this country
atrocious i love sorry i love i suck i'm
serious
it's good there's a there's another
piece to this though so yesterday right
i'm on cnbc and i'm telling people
listen if you were lucky enough to be
one of the early smart guys that started
this short squeeze great
but now you're working people into this
lather because you're talking about
economics
i'm taking economics i know and you're
sucking people and i got a call from a
good friend of mine who i've been trying
to mentor he's like dude i just bought
some of this stock
put a hundred thousand dollars in to to
uh
amc and i was like what price he's like
17. i was like sell it immediately
you know went down to seven the next day
uh i was like so
it's dangerous when the crowd people do
a friendship it's actually not dangerous
i actually think people are losing
they're gonna a lot of people are gonna
lose a lot of money
but that's important to happen because
merit matters
no i look at it like this parents over
cuddle kids
it's good for the kid to skin their knee
i don't want
john from reddit to lose money but
john's a big boy
like john made a decision this is back
to college like made a decision
[ __ ] the system or by the way i
i'm very good at reading things like
this is what i do for a living
90 of them had nothing to do with [ __ ]
anything other than
[ __ ] i could make some money promise
the enormity of people that were going
in were like wait a minute can i make a
quick little
they're the same people that bought
bitcoin and ethereum
or baseball michael jordan they're all
looking for angles there was
an incredible amount of american
capitalism
that was going on everybody's paying
attention like they're gonna burn down
the 88 year old white billionaire fine
cool and there is some of that but let
me promise you something
the person that is the most noble and
hates wall street the most
didn't put their life fortune into amc
they might have bought 50 to make
themselves feel good
but people did what they did for
themselves most people did it because
they wanted to make money
and the people that got caught going up
and now are caught
and lost 1800 bucks they're not gonna
play so fast next time
that's all true but that's all true real
though that's how that this is what i
keep going down to
5.3 billion guy ant you're
anti-paternalism
i'm i'm i'm anti-overreactionism
billion guy you you educated me i didn't
know you're gonna be okay like it's a
hey big l [ __ ] sucks you're gonna be
okay
eighteen hundred dollar john from reddit
loss with four thousand in savings
big l you're gonna be okay and that and
i believe in that [ __ ] novo that's how i
think humans still exist we've had
atomic bombs
since the 50s how the [ __ ] are we still
here i think there's an
underlining protectionism in the
collective
that happens with humans that we do not
talk enough about
i really believe that uh no it's a big
process what are we talking about on
this podcast
you know this we kind of talk about
whatever we want to talk about like
you're talking about nft
yeah nfts my favorite new topic i'm so
obsessed too
i'm spending a ton of time on this in my
own brain for people that don't know
what nfts are right
non-fungible tokens uh these are
one of the great parts about the uh the
whole in the
crypto space the blockchain space
satoshi's white paper is it was the
first
digital signature that you could
encounter fit so think about that means
you can make
digital art that no one can counterfeit
and so all of us on art gets its value
from scarcity and so the blockchain
allows you to do that so now we're going
to see artists for the first time
ever create art digitally right the
great artists
they never did before uh so you're going
to sell digital art you can actually
take your phone you're going to buy it
it's going on your phone you're going to
walk home and you're going to throw it
up on a
giant screen and you're like that's mine
no one else sells that thing that's mine
and so we're going to have collectibles
they're going to create new collectibles
there's going to be instead of baseball
cards
well there's nba top shop they're so
rare shopping blowing up all of a
and so then there will be fractional
things that get sold well that's what's
happening
the fractionalization of physical things
is a game changer
the reason michael jordan's rookie card
is going to a million dollars because
you can sell 100
coverage yes because kenny and staphon
actually want it
i know they do but they're not dropping
350 000
on a single sports card not yet not yet
not yet and i know
and i know them but would they drop 350
bucks if they knew was going to a
million that's no different than buying
a little tesla on apple stock
the fractionalization of sports cards is
going to get that market
insane on the tippy tippy top and so
and you're going to you're going to
fractionalize jerseys you're going to
fractionalize cars or fractionalize all
kinds yeah memorabilia is going to
follow but even bigger than that are
going to be these nfts you're going to
have
the super bowl we're going to you know
mahomes and i'm going to have an
artist do a painting on a digital
painting and a rapper or
you know sing a little song behind him
and then he's going to be up there this
and you're going to sell
that little clip from the super bowl
done by chase
chase hall or whoever the artist is and
people will be like dude
there's only 10 of those and they're
going to buy them and they're going to i
think people need to know how to
showcase them
yeah missing we're in it just for the
record because i want to clip this one
day and say you know i like to do my
content
in nine years i'll clip this and be like
see told you you're 100 right
in one other man's humble opinion
why why art works is
high net worth individuals buy a piece
of art and
whether they put it in a moroccan you
know warehouse or whether they put it in
their upper west side
uh apartment or whether they have a show
that they donated to something they're
able to you know
display it display it they're they're
gonna be able to really reason sports
cards are is because you take a selfie
and put it on instagram we love to flex
i'm waiting to understand the flex
of azation of the nft and as soon as i
understand it
it's coming oh i'm the least confused of
all time i'm curious what it's going to
be
i want to invest in it because it's
going to be the shovels and picks of
that world
we have a we have a uh uh galaxy
interactive fund
uh that's invested in 40. that's the
name of it galaxy interactive what are
you
star trek galaxy star we're more star
wars people
i see the boom effect rito is underrated
and but we invest in 40 companies in the
gaming space vid
new worlds uh in probably a third of
them
they're already playing with these
things we are no question
because we're now 30 40 50 you know year
depending on how you want to look at it
years into the modern internet
really 30 in my opinion um
it's the biggest technology that's ever
happened in the history of life
outside of things like [ __ ] fire and
like
the printing press is the one that i
keep going back to
television phone fine but this is like
printing press
10.0 every piece of our life is
everything is
correct and how we have how we meet
people how we elect officials
you know everything fifty percent of
people today meet their spouse online
that's crazy so a lot of people don't
want the world to change
there's also because i know where how
people are gonna take that line
there's a lot of people that want the
world to change that are gonna be highly
disappointed what the world looks like
it's true
mike why would russia china and america
allow crypto to happen
well there are two pieces to it one
there is an
unbelievable efficiency game and so if
you think about it
banks are rent takers yep
stock markets are rent takers insurance
companies are rent takers and so
crypto at its core cuts out the rent
it's peer-to-peer
i know right and so if you're thinking
for just efficiency gain uh
good for your people if you care about
your people what's funny the
progressives get nervous about crypto
it's the most progressive thing on the
planet a hundred thousand percent but i
tell you the progressive politics
they're like well well listen that's
only just comes from lack of
lack of education one of my missions
this year is to sit down so funny right
to your aoc and the squad
and you literally educate them it's like
dude you've got to be on the team of the
crypto people but people just
we're so used to headlines now people
walk around society
feeling very comfortable talking about
[ __ ] they don't know well that's the one
thing
everyone know how brokerages work i'm
comfortable saying i don't know wall
street
i don't give a [ __ ] the only reason i
even have any stock is because
my private investments went public other
than that it doesn't make me happy
i think it's very logical to invest in
it i also think real estate is logical
i don't invest in that either it doesn't
make me happy
but baseball cards certainly do happy as
[ __ ] specifically basketball
how much tv do you watch very little i
figured that you just feel like you're
listening i spent almost all my time
consuming people
what my people will tell you is that's
what my great gift is that i'm
you know it's funny i'm i talk a lot i'm
sure people that listen in your pockets
like get this [ __ ] guy off he's
talking over michael
i get it because i'm so rarely talking
actually but everybody thinks i'm always
talking because i'm so good at content
creation and distribution
that i'm everywhere but it's not it's in
a very limited window
like you know i do a podcast i'm gonna
get like 8 000 pieces of content out of
this
but i'm really spending 15 hours a day
operating and listening
you two know this but like you know so i
have a very
i've come to realize i'm a really
interesting enigma like i'll spend
three hours in one subreddit listening
interesting i'll spend four hours in a
discord listening i'll spend
years in twitter and instagram reading
just the comments
i knew more about cardi b before i
didn't listen to one of her songs
because i was
listening to people conversating around
and that's how my brain works
so i like learning from documentaries i
love history
because i use it hence where where did
the printing press come from
the fact that history was the only class
i was good at in my entire educational
life
the fact that most of the tv i watch is
documentaries
i like using history to tell me the
future and then i like being in the dirt
and putting in the work to listen to
take the data points
and filter it through history for the
future and that is where my success
comes from how do you unwind
ever do you ever know why i unwind the
new york jets allow me to unwind
tremendously i'm being dead serious
people laugh at this but caring so much
about something that means nothing
is an incredible so they say they they
say they say this there's studies that
say
rabbids force bands have better mental
health because they get all their anger
and all their [ __ ] out by screaming at
the goddamn horrible team they're
rooting for
so i need to do a little homework on
that studies studies
because i actually think i understand
the world through the lens of a jets fan
let me
let me explain i struggle hating people
including right now when it's easier
than ever for people to hate each other
but i hate bill belichick
and i really actually feel it like when
i go to foxboro and go in the stadium
i the things that go through my mind are
the things that people call each other
in politics but in politics i would
never do that
so i'm irrational in sports because it
doesn't mean anything
and then i think about people being
irrational in life
because it means something and so i'm
like this bizarro reverse
on my worst self in football and
basketball have you ever been to a uk
soccer game
i have and i love that [ __ ] because
they're my people it's just because they
really
care i think american sports fans don't
care enough yeah they care
they ca you know like in the uk they
like
football soccer soccer as we say around
the world
speaks to me a lot because they care the
way i care about the jets
i think in america we have a slightly
healthier macro relationship around
fandom
i just don't like i i go to a so you you
like
no i love they have the the chain link
fences between the two least
confrontational person believe it or not
even though
in video and i'm but in real life but i
like want to physically fight
like i i've done the least nice things
that i know about myself have been done
at jet football games last time you
could be a good philadelphia fan too
do you know that i genuinely love
philadelphia sports
because of it and we both hate the
giants i went down
with one of the the owners of the giants
uh
one of the sons of the owners of the
giants when we were working
15 years ago we had giants jackets he
gave me this beautiful giant's jacket
we'd flown a helicopter down we're
walking through the stadium parking lot
and a cop says
dude you should take that off and i said
what are you talking about i'm a
restaurant he's like
take it off and i was like what he's
like take it off
cop big cup so i took it off and carried
it in and
then then i understood i've never seen
that and then i understood what they
were talking about by the way i have
this lugiano if you're listening
raiders playoff game chad pennington
that year we go to raiders we're in our
jet jersey cop goes take the jerseys off
i'm in my combat [ __ ] war zone mood
i'm like no
and i looked at him and said officer i'd
rather die
and i wore my jersey and it got scary to
be honest
it was so scary as [ __ ] i wasn't as
tough as you i took that giant thing
that wrapped it up
i wasn't even that big of a giants fan
i'm literally tough nowhere you can punk
me
society you can punk me anywhere except
a football stadium
i will i'd rather die all right
novo so i do this thing uh called
overrated underrated on instagram
where it's my just personal opinion in
the macro if this thing and you could
obviously take a million angles on it
is overrated by society or under paris
hilton
for me underrated because and i'll tell
you why she understood a lot of what's
going on right now way in advance
what's that way in advance she she
killed so that's why i would say
somebody else would say she's over like
she's also nice i'm aware so here we go
i'm going to throw some words your
teammates some words
i may throw a couple of my own in here
so can he fire away bojangles
bojangles the most underrated brand in
the world next that's that was
self-interest we don't do that on my
show keep going
no you're right wrestling underrated
wrestling
underrated toughest sport in the world
all the mma champs
started as wrestlers it builds grit
builds character
and you're never scared again what about
professional entertainment
love professional wrestling why is it
underrated you know it's underrated
because the theater of it
literally it's changed entertainment it
changed professional sports
vince mcmahon genius he's like walt
disney they just don't realize it yes
on steroids correct yeah actually
blocking blockchain blockchain is
underrated it's going to have its day
it's starting to show
in 15 years the interesting thing is you
won't notice it'll be the back of the
[ __ ] tv
yeah but it's going to change the world
in a really positive way i agree
uh read it read it well i'm learning
about reddit real fast
uh like you know fred all these forums
i think are complicated uh
you know they're i'll give it underrated
because
it's having a huge impact on the world
and it's gonna probably have a bigger
impact but they're complicated in terms
of
how do you edit through to get to yeah
but i think one thing that people are
missing
is that these forums whether it's 4chan
reddit or a facebook group
discord it's just the internet yeah
these are platforms on top of it
fair point you will not stop people from
congregating on the internet unless you
regulate the internet
you can block parlor all you want you
can block reddit
this is why the point i mean you all go
to signal you know
there's somewhere to go but the question
is but governments can stop it
and i think people don't that's where i
don't think they will i think there is a
there is an ethos in our country that
runs through of freedom and
well listen like we're not china right
now we have
both sides you had aoc and donald trump
jr and ted cruz even though they then
fought each other a little more
agreeing on something no no in a big way
no no i really need everybody listen
really agreeing and i think that's an
important insight to everybody a
politician in america
is playing defense 24 7 365
right they have they are constantly
decision making
strictly on the behavior of winning an
election
that's in front of them pure and utter
defense
and even the smartest [ __ ] i know
i've been able to destroy
because i'm playing offense and they're
playing defense and that's the problem
that's a good way to end i gotta go all
right i love you nova hope everybody
thanks gary youtube watcher what's up
it's garyvee first of all thank you so
much i hope you're doing super well
during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon